So here are some of the issues that arise when we
try to accomplish the first step in OOA.
As Jared mentioned, some of the words are duplicated.
You know, we'll try to condense those and
just have one copy of each of the words.
Some words share the same stem, for example, pile and piles.
And some words are, are close to each other and
really share the same underlying concept like leaf and leaves.
And in these cases we're going to do what's called stemming.
Stemming removes the prefixes and the post fixes, the suffixes to the words,
and just uses the root word as the corresponding candidate and class.
That leaves us with a question that you, you, you indicated both counter and
count, okay?
In this case, we're going to use our kind of discretion and say, let's for the,
the moment treat those as separate classes, even though by getting rid of the,
the suffix on counter, we get the same word as count.